there's a bit of a misnomer in the title
which is that these pores not prickly at
all I just I just wanted more of
probability problems like I said there's
no set of Albert there's not an
algorithm that is a set of steps do
these six steps and you'll sketch your
curve and we'll have all the features
you need on it probably it's not like
that is to keep it carefully and use
these principles that are kind of going
to overarching to pop you know what
tools to use in life okay so for
starters anywhere in chance of
probability right please I mean this is
a bit of an obvious thing for you guys
but constructive something anything that
will justify your answer we justify on
something very frequently your house is
just a fraction okay and sometimes that
fraction you're just like you didn't
write it down and that'll be it but
there will be two marks on the question
why and the answer is in looking for
what you used to arrive at that fraction
okay if you see and this is more other
than to unit than extension one
probability but if you see a question
it's been a pretty small number of
possibilities like see six or twelve
okay sometimes ways don't do lets you do
some huge enormous diagram just list the
things out they're not meant to be let
me do crazy some questions will say sure
that there are six ways to do this and
all they mean is can you just write them
down can you list what the six face are
and they will only ask for a list of
that kind it's gonna be a smallness a
disproportionate number of chance
probability questions have to do with a
pair of dice but that's because they're
so easy to work with and it's kind of
like that sweet spot between you know if
you think about changing the ER metaphor
for a second if you think about
polynomials okay
Lydia functions the employer was a super
boring okay cubic polynomials are really
really hard you can't even without the
quadratic Euler
mechanically missus early flight all the
Brits even with the quadratic formula
sometimes you're a bit stuck but
quadratics degree two it's kind of it's
really nice spot in the middle where
it's challenging but it's accessible and
two dice are exactly like that okay so
the way to do two dice questions are
always with a dot diagram or with
agreement I'll show you how they were
difficult a member okay if you've got a
multi-stage event like two or three
things are happening in sequence okay
then do yourself a favor
construct a tree diagram maybe this can
be like just like your grass a third of
a page is a good guideline if not more
sometimes and make sure you label each
branch with the probability of each of
those individual events okay yeah just a
quick reminder when you've got lots of
things happening the same time remember
I said the hardest math should be doing
in probability is add and multiply okay
now the question is when do you add when
do you multiply when you've got the tree
diagram and we will draw something
second you multiply along the branches
okay because if you are tracking the
Long Branch is what you have is events
that are all happening together right
whereas if you're going down the
branches right you're actually thinking
about events that are not happening
together okay so it's like I either pick
two boys or I hit two girls right you
may like to add on to there I forgot the
words that go with these are end all
right if you've got all these things
aren't happening together right if
you've got air then they are so you
multiply there's a really easy way to
think about like if you get confused as
to which one is which and the easy way
is just to think about what age right so
if I said to you okay
what's the probability that I get two
tails in a row just think about that
simple simple question okay and then
think about which of these it will mean
now the probability of getting a single
tail obviously is hot right it's like
well the five two heads in a row
am I going to add a half and a half or
am I going to multiply the hospital
okay did I yeah sorry how about a
multiple offer am I gonna add now
clearly you can't add these together
because then the probability of getting
two tails is a hundred percent every
time easy always bet on tails and then
you're like wait what about three tails
150 was a chance that doesn't make sense
so these events are clearly happening
together that's what you must multiply
right so to be 1/2 times 1/2 that's why
there's only a 25% chance so figure out
a simple event and then think about
which principle you're going to use
again they're happening together
multiply across if they're happening
separately then adverb 1 ok that's the
impression of it ok so I'm talking about
if multiple things are happening so like
a multi-stage event so if I if I for
instance if I flipped through coins okay
I can't like outfit sequins and I
certainly can't catch to you please so
if I flip both of these at the same time
okay
I mean there's a first coin will be my
first set of branches and then my second
coin will be my next set of ranges after
that and I'm gonna have to multiply 1/2
on this liner and a half on this one
that gives me a quarter okay so
yeah so that's why I'm that's why I've
got inverted commas over this
simultaneous word because when we talk
about a multiple stage event we're
thinking about like even if I have a
single coin and I flip it once and then
I flip it again
okay I figured that as one entire event
so I think about they're happening
together even they're chronologically
there's like five seconds between one
and then the other it's like that double
coin flip was a single event okay and
there are four different ways to do it
like it so separate event might be
flipping two heads or flipping shoot
tails right they can't happen at the
same time I can't have two heads and two
tails okay so so I'm thinking about
sequence right so therefore if I have
the breakfast right so that's why it's
like this or that and you'd add up all
right so question might be what's the
probability of flipping the same face
twice right when I flip the two coins
and it'd be like when your head heads or
tails tails and I'm gonna add those up
does that make sense okay last thing
Jack down the bottom if the question
says to you okay here's like 12 people
okay
10m of them are doing this and five of
them are doing that twelve people ten
and five when you see an inconsistent
number or numbers that don't add up what
that tells you is that things are
overlapping right so just make a Venn
diagram a really really simple one and
then use that to count up what's going
on I'll show you